[Music]
thank you very much Francis
yesterday Francis took me aside and said
in very earnest terms
I very much want you to give a good talk
Henry I said well I will do the best I
can I can't promise anything
I think it's an unrealistic expectation
people have unrealistic expectations
from time to time in our society and
that reminded me actually of a bumper
sticker that I saw here some time back
it said in clear block letters us out of
North America
without arguing the merits of that case
or the lack of merit it did seem like
Francis's suggestion to be somewhat
unrealistic the subject of the talk
today the subject certainly is well
known I sure to most of you in the
audience it is a series of experiments
that were carried out at Stanford by an
MIT Schlag collaboration that started in
the early 1960s started to take data in
the deep inelastic reaction in 1968 and
wound down in the early 70s rather
slowly it was a very interesting series
of experiments for the people in it we
and enjoyed it enormous Lee at the time
we're aware of how much fun it was to do
that part of this has to do with the
what Martin and other people Martin
Deutsch in his earlier talk and others
referred to as the Golden Age and if you
remember the rather poignant financial
diagram that Bill wall and Meyer showed
at lunch the other day you remember that
the funds in what I referred to as the
Golden Age climbed up in the period up
to about 1970 and then coasted down
again and leveled out for some years
so the Golden Age is associated at least
in some part with another translation of
the word gold which is gelt which was
the funds that kept it all going and if
it really was in many ways an era which
had for period apparently unlimited
possibilities the MIT Schlag
collaboration was the collaboration part
of this was initiated by Gerry and
myself in the early 1960s we had both
worked at Stanford and been on the
Stanford faculty working in Robert
Hofstadter's group on electron
scattering
and we when the large machine the
two-mile accelerator was was being
contemplated and in fact construction
plans were being laid we wrote beef
Panofsky a letter and said we would like
to join in that group almost all of whom
were our old friends well it was not
just the two of us that were involved
this is a list of the collaborators in
that and I've taken the liberty because
this is an LNS camp gathering -
underlined in red those people who
either were at MIT at the time of the
collaboration or had been educated at
MIT and you could see there were enough
of us so the slack people could not
reliably get away with anything we were
we Jerry and I particularly were
enormous ly well bountifully supported
not just in financially although that
seemed to be the tenor of the time but
also in some sociological sense by the
physics department under then chairman
Bill Buckner who many of us remember he
basically allowed Jerry and me to become
a single hyphenated professor in the
department and we were able to split the
travel to slack between us in any way we
chose I being single at the time over
not quite ten years spent nearly a third
of my time out there it was one of the
first big heavy-duty collaborations that
people in the physics department had
engaged in and it set the tone for a lot
of the subsequent good collaborations
that have occurred between LNS people
and work at distant accelerators now the
to begin to lead into the subject of
electron scattering but both of us Jerry
and I as I said had been with
Hofstadter's group Hofstadter's a
principal and quite great contribution
was to study the elastic scattering of
high-energy electrons from the proton
and from the neutron and in summary the
sort of thing he found was that as you
increase the momentum transfer the
observed scattering cross-sections
coasted down much faster with a momentum
transfer then one would expect from the
scattering of a point charge and this is
due directly to the fact that as you
increase the momentum transfer the
contributions to the outgoing wave from
components distributed over space
interfere more and more and give you
this dramatic decrease and this is
interpreted and was interpreted at the
time as the result of the finite
distribution and finite structure of the
proton and later experiments have
carried that curve out further and
unlike the nuclear atom there was no
hint in this extended data of any hard
single Center in the proton and the were
physicists who concluded publicly that
therefore the proton had no hard
constituents and no core in it at least
certainly not a single core now the
reaction which we studied was the
inelastic scattering of electron this is
the finaland diagram for them the
electron that travels along here in
vacuum there's a single interaction here
comes the proton there is some momentum
transfer which is can in the laboratory
be adjusted so that one knows what it is
if there is an energy transfer just the
difference between the incoming and
outgoing electron energies and there is
some amount of energy communicated to
the proton or neutron as the case may be
in simply blowing it up and that becomes
in the inelastic case a variable which
is subject to adjustment and you study
various you study the cross-sections
over a range of in elasticity this is a
set of all purpose equations that govern
the process because the in the elastic
scattering is unique in that there's no
energy communicated to the struck system
except recoil energy the in elasticity
here has a unique value which is for
that reaction alone momentum transfer is
given here I don't need to go over these
these equations in detail except to note
one or two features that I'll come to in
a later and using it in some of the
later slides that the much of the
development of the central scattering
equation depends unknown quantum
electrodynamics and is not a subject of
investigation but the unknown structure
of the target system is buried in these
two functions W 2 and W 1 each of them
in principle a function of two variables
the inelasticity nu and the momentum
transfer now without going into the
details of it if you look at the
scattering in terms of virtual
transverse and longitudinal photons
there is a quantity of interest which
was measurable in the some of the later
stages of
our experiments which is conventionally
called are the ratio of the longitudinal
to the transverse yields and it turned
out as we will see in a minute to be
useful to determine that because of the
role it played in the validity of some
of the models now it's one thing to
write down a finaland diagram that is
simply paper work but to get at the part
of these measurements you need equipment
and this is not Martin deutsches
tabletop equipment anymore
here is the 2-mile linear accelerator at
Stanford this is route 285 which is
indeed out of the radiation field it is
also not true that the San Andreas Fault
cuts across the accelerator line it is
in fact a quarter of a mile from the gun
this machine the actual accelerator
itself is roughly forty feet underground
was at the time and may still be the
single largest single cantilevered
structure that the human race has
constructed and at the time at where the
device was built it was certainly the
most precise machine of any sort that
had been built the beams after the
acceleration was completed which would
be below that point roughly on the
diagram were sent into a beam switchyard
and could be energy analysed and
deflected into one of several
laboratories this early picture does not
show the colliding beam facility that
were installed later our experiments
were done with a deflection toward the
north into this rather large 250 foot
shielded building these beams are
biologically very potent and the whole
building was heavily shielded one could
not go in it during machine operation
the emergent beam
it came out through a pipe here and then
was buried in the hill this hill never
got the quixotic names that the earlier
Hill had in the high energy physics
laboratory where it was called Mount
Panofsky and rumors were that giant
mutant frogs would lope around in the
evening having been affected by the
radiation you will instantly recognize
this diagram as an experimentalist
Fineman diagram and like the earlier
Fineman diagram the initial beam comes
down here in vacuum in our case in an
aluminum pipe tempted to refer to it as
the false vacuum but it really isn't
it's an imperfect vacuum electrons are
deflected in a hydrogen target there
into a large one or another Magnetic
Spectrometer which were built for the
purpose the detector arrays enable one
to determine these precise scattering
angle actually a number of scattering
angles were accepted by the equipment
and determined by the detectors the
recoil system in our experiments was let
go by itself we didn't made no attempt
to do coincidences or to study it at all
this is just one diagram of the one of
the two large detectors that we used
they were fairly substantial devices the
beams primary beams came down here were
measured brought to fossae their
intensities determined positions monitor
and so forth with liquid hydrogen
targets they were sort of typically nine
nine inches or a foot in diameter or so
some smaller some larger and and upward
a double flat flat magnet bend into a
substantial shielded detector housing
these devices are not large now by the
conventional detector sizes used at the
colliders but at the time they were they
were very large instruments a weighing
of the order these with the shielding of
several thousand tons of these things
opened up like clam shells giving us
access to the to the elements MIT did
much of the detect oral design and
construction as well as the electronic
systems in the counting-house now let
let us leave the experimenters to their
the switches and fuses for a minute and
turn to a theoretical interlude which
I'll call the 1968 hadron which is the
scene so to speak at the time our
experiment started as far as the
experimental situation was concerned in
the late 1950s and 1960s there had been
a remarkable series of discoveries that
involved identifying dozens of hadrons
hydronic resonances at the strong
interaction machine that been quite a
body of work done studying
Payan and proton scattering from nucleon
target and
the Energy's not being as high as
they're now available it turns out that
those studies showed what you would call
soft constituents and soft interactions
namely cross sections which decreased
exponentially with increasing
perpendicular momentum and the coupled
with the Hofstadter results the general
picture of the hadron was of a rather
soft device which underwent sus what you
would call soft interactions on the with
respect to classification murray
gell-mann and others had helped
elaborate the so-called Eightfold way
which had classified these numerous new
discoveries into identifiable and sorted
arrays and in 1964
Gelman an independently George Zweig
proposed that the basis for these
classification schemes could be a basis
could be constructed with a mathematical
entity which Murray called quark there's
been some discussion about the origin of
the name and from its inventor I will
tell you that he invented the name first
out of blue sky as a word just a sound
which he would have spelled qu o RK
later he found the word used in I think
it was what Finnegan's Wake and he
adopted that spelling but retained the
old pronunciation so that's where it
came from they had the unusual property
of having fractional requiring
fractional charges and it was quite a
successful scheme theoretically the
proposal of quark stimulated a number of
quarks searches which went on for a
number of years and quarks were searched
for in cosmic rays without success
they were searched for in by as
hopefully being produced in accelerators
and identified there without success and
they were searched for in an array of
experiments reminiscent of the Milliken
oil-drop experiment searching for charge
fractional charges without success
separately there was a body of theory
the s-matrix
theory with a number of elaborations
which dealt quite well with with the
then-known scattering cross-sections of
various kind and among these and I don't
want to go into them in great detail was
vector Mezen dominance there because of
the failure to identify isolated quarks
in the various classes of experiments in
which they had been searched for the
proposition that nucleons were in fact
constructed of quarks had a rather rough
time there was a very small industry and
that was that looked at the proposition
and tried to calculate nucleon
properties and resonance properties
based on the what is what was was called
is called the Constituent quark model
and the Constituent quark model was to
some extent different than the quarks
that were required for as the basis of
the classification schemes the and this
this constituent quark model attracted
very very few adherence and proponents a
few people persisted Dalitz Morpurgo
and others primarily dealing with low
energy reactions of one sort or another
and had on characteristics but not
having a not attempting to push these
two high energy high
transfer reactions the reason that most
of the theoretical community including
incidentally some of its very
distinguished members found that the
theory of the whole proposition of
constituent quarks was unattractive was
based as I mentioned partly on the idea
that partly on the experimental evidence
that nobody had produced them or seen
them also on the theoretical requirement
that in order to be satisfactory in the
models they had to employ very very
strong binding which was upsetting and
the problem that while these things were
expected to be spin 1/2
they had symmetric statistics which was
troublesome and of course the fractional
charge violated every piece of
experimental evidence that had before
that time been accumulated now some of
these constraints were removed in some
theories but nevertheless the aggregate
of them made a constituent court picture
quite unattractive and it was generally
not believed one other thread was the
set of theories called current algebra
it it was initiated by Murray gell-mann
and was a quite abstruse theory the
experimenters in in our group I think we
generally did not understand it really
very well and it did not play any real
part in the its predictions in the
planning of our experiments but it did
have one current so to speak that
affected us later
be it the based on the current algebra
ideas there was started first by Adler
and then gross and Llewellyn Smith and
others a some rural industry and Jim B
arcane who was an old friend became
involved in that
and use those techniques to predict
something which I will come back to
later called scaling so to summarize the
1968 had run we had there was at best a
rather cloudy idea of the dynamics there
was a quark model which was whose
successes were in the mathematical
domain but whose practical application
as constituents was simply not really
believed there were a number of
candidates with theories which in
principle would apply to the sorts of
reactions we were about to study one of
them as I mentioned was vector Mezen
dominance Sam has talked about that a
heavy photon if you like the reason it
was a live candidate was because it had
been quite successful in processes that
involve real photons and as I've noted
on this viewgraph here many people
believe that it would succeed in dealing
with the virtual photons which we could
adjust in our experiments to be quite
far off the mass show
nevertheless the expectation is that
this process would happily let us
understand the deep inelastic cross
section and one of the consequences of
adopting this view was that it was not
expected that one would see anything
more than a continuously fuzzy proton
and neutron a couple of quotations on
the possibility of real quarks being
constituents of nucleons and and others
strongly interacting particles say
remark of murray gell-mann x' or two
remarks taken from up phys Rev the
physical physics letters paper of 1964
in which it's quite clear from what he
said that while he doesn't utter ly
reject the idea that there might be
constituents in there he certainly
doesn't think that's the first
think certainly not saying well I think
they're there go look for them folks
quite the opposite and an an even
stronger statement in Kaka Dee's book on
the court model in which he almost
refers to the idea in scathing terms
referring to it as tentative and
simplistic expression and ill found it
well so I think one could feel that we
were not too badly off base designing
equipment to study the rather low cross
sections that were expected on the basis
of the current current thinking but when
we got to make the first inelastic
measurements we found something quite
surprising this is one of the first
surprises and this is the earliest data
in which we observed it as a function of
momentum transfer horizontally two
different cuts at two GeV in elasticity
and three you see the data moving across
here with hardly any momentum transfer
dependence at all and compared with this
just arbitrarily normalized the
consequences of elastic scattering and
the enormous decrease in yield that is a
consequence of the finite structure of
the aggregate proton when it is
undisturbed in the elastic reaction
so this was certainly a discovery and
when the dust had settled and we had a
chance to look around later and compare
what our measurements were with what our
preliminary or expectations have been we
found this measurements that were
enormous predictions on which the
experimental equipment had been based
low there's a factor of over 40 here
this was taken at a primary energy of 16
GeV primary electrons at a scattering
angle of 6 degrees the such deviation
has become even more pronounced at
larger momentum transfer the second
discovery was as in a sense it was
directly suggested to us I happen to be
doing the data analysis at the time so I
was by chance the fella that first saw
this what happened was we and I had been
looking at the inelastic spectra and
here are six of them at different this
is now plotted in a different way than
the earlier graph each of these spectra
is at a constant momentum transfer and
it's plotted as a function of energy
laws these are the two independent
variables that you have in principle
available and you can see on this plot
that the data scatters around and it you
can take my word that if one extends the
range of momentum transfer the rest of
this region in here eventually gets
filled with data and there's no obvious
pattern in that Jim pure cane came to
see me one day and in his rather gentle
hesitant way he had something very
powerful to say he said well why don't
you look at the data that you have
accumulated as a function of a single
variable a combination of
new and q squared and see whether this
doesn't explain in a consolidated way
what you are measuring and I did that
there was one parameter in this that we
did not at that stage no not having any
measurements of it that was that
quantity R that I mentioned earlier the
ratio of longitudinal transverse I took
the data and plotted it for the two
limiting cases are equal infinity and
are equal zero and what happened was a
spectacle R I mean essentially under my
eyes this data consolidated into a
compact Universal curve for either
either of the two limiting cases and I
remember at the time the the little
tingle I had looking at this and I
recall thinking how Bohr must have not
bore but Ballmer must have felt went
with his empirical expression whose
origins he had no idea theoretically he
had found this is a beautiful
understanding of the series in the
hydrogen atomic spectra so it was clear
that BJ had really gotten his hands on
something here and this that was scaling
and this is the first plot that you see
here was the discovery of scaling in
deep inelastic electron scattering as
time went on and as the program advanced
we got much better data we were able to
unscramble and separate the
contributions from the two inelastic
form factors that I mentioned each of
them turned out indeed to be a function
of a single variable I'll come to its
specifications in a minute but you see
them here consolidating a wide range of
Nu and Q squared in two relatively
Universal curves now as the experiments
continued and became more precise and we
got more data it was found that there
were minor variations
that this was not an absolutely strict
rule there was some scale breaking but
it was a very of a very small character
compared to the gross scaling that was
observed so this has ultimately become
effectively
almost a law of nature now to be
specific about what BJ had done as I
mentioned based on rather arcane the
application of current algebra he had
predicted what is now bears his name the
hurricane scaling and the be arcane
limit and to be specific in the limit in
which the energy loss goes to infinity
the momentum transfer likely likewise
goes to infinity that as this ratio is
held fixed to M mu over Q squared that
the quantity Omega becomes the variable
on which these structure functions
depend how pass over the lower part
which is elaborated in this next slide
because it was not very long after those
first measurements but people were
scratching their head over there
meaning that Fineman came up to visit us
in the summer of 1964 and heard about
these measurements and he had been
attempting to understand hadron Hadron
interactions on the basis of a
constituent model not quarks just
constituents parts of the proton which
he gave the obvious name part ons to and
Fineman went down to his motel for the
night after talking to Jerry and others
and the next day he came back full of
interest and excitement and with the
following picture that the electron
virtual photon was interacting with a
part on nature unknown and the
what one was one explained the large
cross-sections by the fact that these
part ons were assumed to be essentially
point particles that took care of that
part of the paired discoveries and
second that the scaling variable came
directly out of this picture because we
were scattering elastically from a part
one or another of the particles in there
which were point charge scattering the
difference between scattering off of one
of those and the proton being that a
they carried some fraction each of them
want some fraction of the protons mass
and they were in motion and the scaling
variable is in fact just that relation
which I showed you earlier for elastic
scattering from the proton with the
single proviso that you have a quantity
in there X or it is an X it represents a
fractional mass which is that fraction
of the momentum of the protons momentum
that the part on happened to be carrying
when it was struck and it is struck as a
essentially a free particle
this is a picture that I happen to snap
a Fineman when he came back late that
fall this is a muddy Xerox of it but
there is a color picture over in the
Johnson center where you can see it in
better detail with his enormous vitality
and interest and in that October he gave
his first public talk on the part on
theory the part on not yet being
identified with corks it was a joy to
see him operate here is a little
paragraph from the book he wrote where
he put these things together a few years
later those of you who knew him can can
kind of visualize the enthusiasm he
brought to it I mean look at the wording
of this an exciting adventure to try the
idea that these things are simply quarks
and to meet and surmount the then still
outstanding obstacles to that
interpretation
well the experiments did not stop there
it was a program it went on for a number
of years and the theorists the the
stimulation of these results into the
theoretical community initiated a very
interesting almost fascinating interplay
of theory and experiment which went on
for a number of years and eventually
drawing in other laboratories with other
confirming measurements the experiments
experimental results with themselves
never challenged and were confirmed as
other laboratories looked at similar
analogous reaction but the
interpretations took a long while to
develop it was like watching the grass
grow in total contrast to Richter's
discovery of the side particle the jace
I wear at 4:00 in the morning very
little is happening except a humdrum
incremental e incremental studying of
counting rates and by 8 o'clock they
were breaking open champagne bottles and
putting vodka in the iron
shoes this is quite different in our
case but a few within a few years Kalin
and no very quickly almost to say near
Kalin and grouse showed that in the
framework of this Fineman Parton model
that you could begin to get a handle on
the spins of the constituents that a
particular combination of these form
factors was one if the spin was 1/2 and
0 if it was 0 and remember the quarks
were to be as the mathematical quarks
were to be spin 1 and very quickly we
had an experimental result you see the
red line is the prediction for spin 1/2
the green line is spin 0 and you have no
problem deciding on that one the vector
boson dominance proposals didn't last
very long either they too ran afoul of
some measurements very soon we were able
to make determinations of our not only
for the proton but for the deuteron and
by subtraction for the neutron itself
the vector des on dominance predictions
went up in here there was some
uncertainty the angle but strikingly
different expected behavior then the
data showed and there went the vector
depth dominance models well there as I
mentioned there this interplay of theory
and experiment continued on with more
measurements involving the nucleon now
that is our deuteron and neutron
measurements and let me just wind this
down by going on a brief historical tour
of what happened during the decade of
the 1970s after the original discovery
I've told you about the early
theoretical circumstances slack itself
had been proposed in the period when
many of the
resonances were being discovered for the
first time the classification schemes
were in the early 1960s getting slack
approved by the Congress was a fairly
arduous problem there was considerable
opposition to it to some extent similar
to what has happened with the
superconducting supercollider but was
indeed approved in 1961 the joint
collaboration between us and them
started the following year the shovels
were out in 1963 the machine went on the
year in 1967 on time and within budget
and they essentially turned to switch
and it came right up to beam we just got
used to that what else that does not
always happen in later times in 1968 as
I mentioned the first deep inelastic
proton scattering very quickly Fineman
came in on that with the results I've
discussed those results were presented
in Vienna that September I've shown you
the slide of Fineman actually giving his
first talk at SLAC Callen grouse and the
determination of the spin potential came
in in November the burek Ain and
Pascoe's were doing some rural
evaluations as part of his BJ's work on
current algebra and 1969 the first our
first experimental results on our and
the first papers published that year
then other laboratories came in with the
on the basis of the general interest and
excitement that had been generated one
of the predictions from the part on
theories was that the neutrino
scattering data would show cross
sections which increased linearly with
the primary energy and CERN went back
and looked at earlier data that they
have taken on that reaction
on neutrino cross-sections and
discovered indeed that it increased
linearly so we were beginning to get
outside core corroboration of the
results the following year our electron
deuteron scatterings program started and
we very quickly discovered that the
neutron proton ratio was not one as a
number of the earlier soft proton models
suggested it might be but dropped
dramatically and by the latter part of
that year it was already clear that the
Parton model was beginning to be
accepted that the evidence was beginning
to accumulate by the following year the
NP ratio was found to decrease
dramatically down almost to a quarter
and the theoretical community
simultaneously was beginning to focus
more and more on the nature of the
constituents on the nature of the
photons there there was a theory that
drow looked at assuming they were
nucleons if I remember but Julius cootie
and Vicky were beginning to look at the
first of the quark model the dedicated
neutrino experiments were beginning to
show results by late 1971 and the whole
body of diffractive models was beginning
to be weeded out and discarded and later
some of the more abstruse predictions of
the cork what then became called the
cork Parton model began to get some
experimental verification the anti
neutrino neutrino cross-sections turned
up to favor spin 1/2 as the slack
earlier results had done
because the neutrinos have no charge the
fractional charge peculiarities which
were inherent in the electron scattering
cross-section did not affect the
neutrino cross-section so it was
possible to make a cross determination
to see whether the fractional electric
charges were in fact what one was seeing
in the slack yields and lo and behold
the fractional charges turned out to
give predictions in agreement with the
measurements there was a confirming
measurement of the number of valence
quarks we had found from some rule
evaluations that we could not account
for all of the momentum carried by the
protons by looking at the sums over
cross-sections and it was concluded that
at least some fraction which looked like
about half of the protons momentum was
carried by entities with which the
electrons did not interact and these are
now known as the gluons so this is quite
indirect measurement but our
determination but that's where gluons
first sort of started to show their head
through the shrubbery
by 1973 theoretical development by
Politzer gross and we'll track began to
tell us how it was that we could conduct
scattering from what appeared to be a
free quark and yet these things remained
bound were not visible as free entities
that was a very important theoretical
development and then on the heels of
that came the formulation of quantum
chromodynamics
and the beginnings of the understanding
of the small but but quite clearly
observed scale breaking was that we were
seeing well you can look at the rest of
these results what we go into through
these subsequent years has been the
subject of a good deal of what Sam has
been talking about and earlier talks and
I think I don't have to go through that
but what happened over the rest of this
decade was a slowly consolidating
feeling that indeed the Parton's were
quarks who a part of this was the
discovery of the Jace I and other things
which you see and by the time the decade
had wound out the 1968 Hadron was gone
was gone forever
and it was replaced by a nearly complete
theory quantum chromodynamics which had
by then been linked with the weak
interaction theory to form a carry which
in principle one could calculate with
and which entirely replaced what had
been in place before our experiments had
started thank you very much
you